so we're gonna be talking about
simplicity today but in order to talk
about simplicity we need to talk about
the opposite and it turns out that the
opposite is remarkably easy to achieve
it is easy to make anything complicated
in fact this guy Rube Goldberg made a
career of complication he drew cartoons
like how to open a bottle of beer in the
most complicated way possible so for
decades he published these cartoons in
fact we use complication to great effect
in media and in other places who we have
cartoons for example the best way to go
skiing when you don't have snow is to
strap an ice maker and an ice grinder to
your back Dick Van Dyke makes breakfast
for his children in
chitty-chitty-bang-bang Willy Wonka
drives the Wonka mobile which is a burp
powered device we have games mousetrap
is about complicated experiences we even
have art how many of you have been to
the Exploratorium in San Francisco and
recognize this this is a model of the
city made of tens of thousands of
toothpicks over many many years in which
ping-pong balls roll on hidden tracks
through the insides of the contraption
so complicated artwork these things
entertain us they make us laugh right we
don't typically try to make our digital
products complicated but when we do it
intentionally there's something funny
about it there's something fun about it
and in fact lings cars drives more
traffic to this auto dealer in the UK
than any other auto dealer website right
so they're using the complication to
effect now most of the time however we
are not trying to intentionally
complicate our products but there may be
times such as dark patterns where
complication is used to create confusion
to mislead people to do things they
would not otherwise chosen to have done
so we don't want to fall on the dark
side of using complication so just don't
know that little caution aside let's go
ahead and move in because it turns out
that we really don't plan to add
complication to our products it just
kind of seems to happen right it's like
we were going along and everything was
fine and then all of a sudden we turn
around and we look back and it's like oh
I have no idea where my lamp cord is
right or in the server room I have no
idea which one came unplugged so we need
to work to simplify it takes effort to
simplify things entropy in physics is
the natural state of the universe things
become complicated and it takes energy
to make them structured and simple and
it's the same thing for the work that we
do so Picasso gives us what is probably
one of the very best explorations of
complication and simplicity in art if
you take a look at this timeline over
the course of about six weeks he does a
series of explorations in drawing a bull
and you'll notice at the beginning he
starts with something that looks fairly
Picasso ish and then he adds an
increasing amount of detail to it until
he gets to a bull that he feels captures
all of the necessary requirements and
then he begins to subtract and explore
and what can I take away and how can I
get to the essence of bull in this
illustration and when I find really
fascinating about the sequence is that
his penultimate illustration but one
over there right at the end he's like ah
crap too far took too much out and so in
the very final illustration he puts just
enough back for it to be unmistakeably a
ball and the unmistakeably Picasso but
it's a very good illustration of how he
worked hard to find what is necessary
and eliminated everything else now let's
think about the products that we work on
as systems so I'm gonna take a fairly
mathematical and physics kind of
approach to design today and I find it
really helpful for us to break it down
into the parts that we can talk about
things that we can define and methods
that we can use so systems have
variables and they have rules right it's
like it's a formula we understand from
physics and math and systems talk about
things like rate of change and the
current state and the behavior or
actions of the components of that system
now you can see it's pretty easy to see
things like people and context and rules
and context and conditions and
interactions represented here so when we
describe a systems there are these four
things that we want to talk about how
many variables are there in this system
is it a few or is it many what type of
rules are we dealing with here are they
static linear rules where you put a
little in you get a little out or are
they dynamic rules where you put a
little in but you might get a lot out or
next time a little comes out maybe it
fluctuates the inputs and the outputs
are not directly related or not directly
correlated is it a deterministic system
in other words can I predict the future
state can I predict a future condition
or is it difficult to predict I'll give
you a hint
anytime you put a human into a system it
becomes unpredictable so if you're
designing things for people you're
probably already dealing with a
non-deterministic system and is the
system adaptable when the conditions
when the context around that system
change is it able to adjust and adapt
and find a new sort of baseline a new
standard for it to operate or does it
just completely collapse and fall apart
and so once again most of the things
that we're working on we want them to be
adaptive we want them to be able to
adjust to the context and the
so systems now there's different degrees
of complication in a system and and at
the very basic level we have simple
systems right and I'm just gonna talk
about them in terms of ease of use and
ease of understanding and give you an
alternate physics definition up there so
simple systems they're easy to
understand and they're easy to use and
they tend to have a small number of
parts complicated systems on the other
hand they're hard to understand they're
hard to use and they tend to have a
large number of parts but then there are
these complex systems they're hard to
understand but any one of the components
by itself is actually fairly easy to
understand and use but when you put them
all together it suddenly becomes much
more difficult so there's this weird
relationship between the little bit is
easy but the rest of it all put together
isn't and then we have chaotic systems
now chaotic systems are a whole other
mathematical class we'll talk about them
in a moment because no matter what you
put into them it's hard to predict
what's going to come out so we're
typically not designing chaotic products
right and if we are it's because you're
the artists in the room and you're
trying to do things that are going to
surprise people but if you're trying to
pay pay your bills at your online bank
you do not want that to be a chaotic
system do you have enough money yes haha
I know you don't all right so we can
also visualize these systems simple
complicated complex and chaotic how the
captions working by the way I'm not
reading anything all right okay yeah go
google your awesome
so we're gonna focus on the two in the
middle we're going to talk about the
complicated products these are the
things that we can do something about
and a little bit about the complex
products because these are often
circumstances that we need to design
within so we're just gonna focus on
those we obviously don't need to focus
on the simple stuff it's already simple
alright so here we are now we're focused
on these two we've already said that the
complicated products are hard to
understand and hard to use and the
complex products are hard to understand
but individual components might not be
let's redefine these first moment I like
to think of a complicated experience a
complicated system is a system of many
parts lots of pieces right but a complex
system is a system of systems there's
now a nested hierarchy in there and each
of the subsystems might be simple but
together they're difficult so now I hope
you're getting why we're trying to face
these two sets or these two types so
what about the chaotic systems why are
we not going to do anything about that
well chaos has some remarkable
properties they look like really big
massive variable extremely complicated
complex systems but it often turns out
that the math under them is remarkably
simple and there might be only a few
variables that are necessary to define
what that chaotic system is now we've
known about chaos for a while and one of
the first places where we actually found
it in the real world and were able to
model it mathematically was back in the
early 1960s when Lorenz was looking at
atmospheric patterns for weather and we
were just getting to the point where we
could send up satellites and we were
starting to realize that we could
monitor things on the planet we built a
whole network of weather stations around
the planet we were gathering more data
and yet we still had crappy weather
predictions and for the next couple of
decades we still didn't get weather
predictions that were very accurate
beyond seven to ten days which is pretty
much where we
and today 60 years later our weather
predictions haven't gotten any better
because weather is a chaotic system and
when you take a look at the atmospheric
dynamics those three differential
equations right there those simple
looking little equations represent a
chaotic system and weather exhibits a
characteristic called sensitivity to
perturbation which means a little change
here can produce massive changes in the
future
but we don't know when those massive
changes will happen soon mid term long
term I don't know what we know about
chaotic systems is that they are in fact
bounded systems the weather will always
be within that attractor that little
visual there tells us this is what
weather looks like we just don't know
where it will be within that attractor
at any point in time beyond the near
future so we can't predict right now it
turns out these are universal laws this
is the South Pole of Jupiter we've had a
bunch of people here talking to us about
amazing space things for the past couple
of days and one of the amazing things is
we send a spacecraft out to take close
up photos of planets and when we go to
the gas giants like Jupiter and we get a
close-up shot we see things that look
like weather patterns that are just like
earth except of course each one of those
little storm systems is probably bigger
than the planet Earth but at that scale
those laws still apply the weather on
Jupiter is as chaotic as the weather on
earth so we can't simplify chaos we
really can't do anything to make chaos
predictable in fact chaos is a good
thing it's a sign of a healthy system
because chaotic systems are very
adaptable and they can heal and they can
adjust and they can change but we can't
actually make it easier so we're not
dealing with chaotic systems here today
because we just have to live with it
there's nothing we can do about it
recognize that be in awe of it but we
can't change it so we're gonna stick to
the complicated but sometimes some
systems are naturally complex right
things systems of systems they are out
there we have to design for it I love
this image traffic circles now if you
think about traffic circles this is a
system of systems each one of those cars
is a system each one of the people
pedestrian or in the car is part of a
human system we've also got roadway
markings and rules which are part of a
regulatory system and all of these
things are designed to try and make
operating among them easier so that we
don't kill all the people crash all the
cars or ignore all the rules so we do
design to help people deal with
complexity and although it may not look
like it this design does make driving
through this intersection easier right
so we're using design to help people it
is still complex but we can deal with it
so now we have focused completely too
often things that we deal with are
complicated so let's talk a little bit
about how might we get there so how many
of you have ever been stuck in a parking
garage yeah you always get hands up
right especially if you're in a foreign
country and you can't read the signs so
I have another peculiar little side
hobby and that is taking photographs of
parking garage kiosks because they are
universally complicated experiences they
confuse people they are unclear and
there are great examples here is a hint
if you have designed a product that
complete strangers will take the time to
write down instructions and tape it to
your product for other complete
strangers
you've got a complicated product okay
you should do something about it so
parking garage kiosks I got stuck in the
underground garage in Bulgaria one time
one light bulb in the entire underground
garage and finally I just like left on
foot and came back with a friend the
next day
so if complication happens if we find
ourselves in this situation what do we
do first let's understand how do we how
do we get there what actually happened
to introduce this complication right so
if we think about it when we start any
project and we can do a show of hands
here as well when you start a project
you're like yeah I got this I got the
brief I understand the specs the
requirements the scope whatever it
happens to be I've done something like
this before I know the methods to apply
I know what technologies we need this is
gonna be easy
then we start in it and then someone
Longway says oh by the way there is this
other feature there is another
requirement and it has to run on
batteries only or something like that
you're like okay I'll adjust a little
bit and then someone says oh wait I have
an idea wouldn't it be cool if and then
they say something that really is cool
and so then everyone is like yes we're
in do it at it that'll be amazing the
client loved it then at some point
someone on the client side says looks
good or a parachuting creative director
says looks good now let's do and then
they come up with a whole set of changes
right and someone on the on the PMT more
on the business side says these are
change orders clients not gonna like
that then once we start getting to
implementation point maybe some of the
engineers are saying well you know the
technology doesn't actually do that or
yeah we can't use that or we are
restricted to this and now suddenly we
have to change the design in order to
maintain the intent but execute in a
different way eventually however we get
to a point where all of the little
checkboxes on the list of things to do
is done and the team collectively chugs
abeer collapses to the floor and says oh
thank god let's just get it done and out
the door right unfortunately what's
happened at this point in time is that
we have basically designed ourselves to
feature complete and maximum
complication
so yeah it's done yeah it does
everything but it's not necessarily
simple or elegant or easy so what
happened along that path up whole bunch
of things might happen maybe it's some
poor design methods I know none of you
in here would do that
maybe it's poor product management I
know all of you think your partners out
there do that but they don't maybe there
are technical issues I know all of you
implicitly trust your engineers to make
the best decisions and never frustrate
you at all or maybe it's just external
constraints and requirements things like
this happen they change our intent they
change our plan they change where we end
up it might still do what it's supposed
to do just not simply so complication
occurs gradually sneaks up on us right
not quite as cute is the kitten but when
you're not looking it pounces eventually
however we get to a point where someone
or some people on the team have a moment
of insight the light bulb goes off and
they're like oh oh this could be better
I know right let's make it simpler let's
come back we'll revise that will change
a few things we'll get rid of some of
this complication now I want to step
aside for a moment say let's take a
caution sometimes things might not be as
simple as they could be
for a reason I really don't want any
world military with weapons of mass
destruction to license
Amazon's one-click checkout right we
have two people two keys multiple codes
and encryption to slow things down for a
reason could we launch missiles on the
rest of the world more easily yeah
staples has a button for it yeah one big
red button right ah done but we don't
want to
we shouldn't that sometimes too much
simplicity can be a bad thing
now here are and there's a new product
right now these all sound like great
ideas right I'm out of shaving cream I'm
out of razors I'm out of trash bags or
Ziploc bags or whatever I'm out of the
laundry detergent and I'm wearing my
last pair of underwear for the fourth
time send me things I need click and
it's ordered and the next day it arrives
in a nice Amazon van but simplicity
might not always be that goal right it
might not always be ideal so things
might go wrong if an experience is too
fast or too easy maybe people are more
likely to make mistakes maybe some of
the mistakes they make are irreversible
maybe they really don't understand the
outcomes of their actions and don't
anticipate what's going to happen or
maybe it's so easy they never even learn
how it works and they just glossed right
over it maybe the easy things are being
used to mislead people
maybe there's unforeseen circumstances
or unforeseen consequences so at a
conference like this everyone is looking
forward to the end of the day and this
sounds like a really awesome idea beer
me right
what if however you are a recovering
alcoholic with addiction problems should
it be that easy what if you are and
supervise teenager with friends should
it be that easy what are the unintended
consequences of super simple
interactions so sometimes a little bit
of difficulty a little bit of complexity
or complication might be a good thing so
you have to think about that last
example here there's a reason why when
you are investing in your retirement or
or in stocks or mutual funds or whatever
that it's not a one-click purchase
because when you spend that money it
could be very very bad you might be
making bad investment choices you might
lose everything
so our government's regulate financial
services and they make sure that you are
inundated with information necessary to
make a reasonable decision about what to
do with your finances and then when you
say I want to buy something they ask you
three times are you sure
and then they schedule the transaction
to happen at some future time just in
case you have regret later and decide
you need to cancel it so there are these
little traps that they sort of slow you
down with to help make sure you don't
make bad decisions to help you avoid the
unintended consequences so we have to
balance our goals for simplicity we want
to reduce right we want it to be faster
more efficient we want people to have it
easier fewer clicks less time fewer
errors but we also need to consider that
we want to enhance things like the
meaningfulness and the quality of the
experience or the value it provides and
that might actually mean adding some
content or information or some steps to
a flow and we want to help people learn
what's going on maybe creating more or
sharing the right things or remembering
what they are supposed to remember and
so we want to slow them down and give
them time to consider and learn so we
are always optimizing it's a balancing
act right we want to reduce we want to
enhance we want to help
maybe instead of measuring things like
how many clicks how much time and how
few errors we should instead be thinking
about how do we measure whether or not
people have been effective and are they
learning and do they feel confident
maybe that's a metric that we should be
considering for simplicity instead of
just web analytics so Einstein said make
everything as simple as possible right
but no simpler cautioning us on don't go
too far so let's play a game here for a
moment I'm going to slowly reveal some
information here and when you think you
know what you are seeing stay quiet
but raise your hand okay so watch as the
information is revealed when you think
you know what it is stay quiet
but just raise your hand no it's so easy
I see the hands going up in sight okay
all right okay so this is all the detail
I'm giving you how much detail is
necessary to recognize this in other
words how much can I simplify it and
still have it be meaningful how many of
you recognize that's Damien Hirst's
circles drawing Mickey Mouse based on
Walt Disney's Mickey Mouse right the
thing about this is you only recognize
it if you already know what it is does
anyone in here has has never seen or
heard of Mickey Mouse right yeah so you
eventually got to a moment of
recognition because you've already had
experience you already knew what it was
you were just waiting for the moment of
recognition but if you had never ever
seen or heard of Mickey Mouse before you
would have had no idea what that
arrangement of dots was and you might
not even have concluded that it was a
mouse so in some cases we might not have
enough detail or we might not have
enough prior experience for people to
understand what's going on
so we want to use the law of parsimony
also known as Occam's razor and that
basically says you know that all things
being equal the simpler solution tends
to be the better solution and so we do
still strive for simplicity we just
don't want to take it too far all right
so we're at the top of this curve we've
checked off all the boxes we've got all
of the functionality and the content and
the features are in it is at maximum
complication but we're done we're tired
we're exhausted we're frustrated what
are we gonna do what can we do about the
fact that we are at the top of this
curve well if we really do nothing
there's just going to be wrapping up the
project and we'll probably find a few
bugs and tweaks that we want to make and
we will pretty much ship it as is it
will go out relatively soon with a few
improvements but it's still going to be
a complicated product right now the
problem with this is that a sufficiently
motivated person is going to tolerate an
inordinate amount of poop emoji they're
gonna tolerate an inordinate amount of
crap right if you are lucky enough to
have a product that has no competitors
and is required by your customers you
can be as bad as you want but if there
are competitors or your customers don't
actually need it they don't have to
stick around for it
so you shouldn't just launch it as is
you need to do something so what is it
you've got some options if you want to
put a little bit of more time and effort
into making it simpler you can do a
superficial pass you can clean up the
design you can clean up the content
maybe rearrange a couple little things
but you simply improve the clarity the
superficial clarity of the product if
you put a little more time and effort
into it maybe you can rearrange some of
the components or revise some of the
components remember the system of
systems idea maybe you make some parts
of it simpler maybe you make a few
navigational changes or something like
that you you can start to change the
underlying structure of the product but
if you really push it further maybe you
can change how people move through the
product and use it itself maybe you
improve the flow of the entire process
the flow through the systems but that
takes more time and effort in order to
get to that lower level of complication
so this is the point where the client
and the PM says your design complete and
you want to keep designing yep why
because we still need to simplify
we've only achieved feature complete we
have not achieved simplification now
along that uphill climb to that feature
complete point we probably missed a lot
of opportunities that would have been
signals for us that we were introducing
complication so let's quickly run
through a dozen signs that maybe you're
complicating your product right so what
are these
maybe if you are designing for yourself
you make the product more complicated
you really don't understand who the user
is maybe if you start with a technical
opportunity look at this cool thing we
can do let's put it in the product -
people need it who cares it's cool
maybe you're adding complication
maybe you've mapped the structure of the
product to your organization or to the
technology it doesn't match the mental
model of what people need and understand
it matches your org chart or your server
room that's not gonna work maybe product
by consensus you don't do anything
unless everyone agrees that you're going
to do it and so you collectively end up
with a bunch of bad decisions where
everybody gets the one thing that they
want because they've negotiated with the
others to vote for it maybe you made
assumptions at the beginning of the
project and failed to test them
throughout and so now those assumptions
have become accepted fact in a product
but they were never evaluated maybe you
just went out and said what someone else
doing what are the competitor solutions
what are the other things that have
already been done and let's just do that
and then you choose to copy the wrong
thing what if you are asking people to
connect the systems or connect the dots
or do one thing here then take it to
this other place over here
copy information out of this tool put it
into a spreadsheet do some calculations
copy the answer and then put it in over
there because we don't have enough time
to build the connection between those
two tools that's gonna complicate things
what if you say let the user decide
that's going to complicate things if you
get feedback from your users it's messy
and confusing oh for pete's sake listen
to them
right they're telling you I'm confused
you don't say they don't know what
they're doing you say why are you
finding this confusing maybe someone on
the team says wouldn't it be nice to
have
if you're trying to be everything to
everyone and so there is no focus and
there are no priorities and everything
is treated equally and so no one can
figure out what to do catch me for
drinks and I'll tell you a story about
how I sat in a room with the CEO of
Schwab and watched a prototype fail on
12 out of 12 customers over the course
of two days on the last one you add
things to the product just in case
someone might need it right it was just
a weekend trip I thought we'd need these
things it's probably complicated so what
do we do how do we reduce the
complication well the first off let's
start with just good solid foundational
design methods and I'm gonna breeze
through these because y'all are good
foundational designers so I'll leave it
up for a second at the end if you wanted
to take a photo first off identify
define and frame what you are trying to
achieve what's the problem what's the
challenge what's the desired outcome
what's the desired resolution just be
really clear about what you're trying to
work on and why don't define it as you
go user-centered design methods remember
it's not for you it's for someone else
so know who they are please please
please take a logic class in college
improve your critical thinking and your
analytical skills and your
problem-solving methods and then iterate
I would love to be able to say that I'm
brilliant and I get the things perfect
on the first time around it has never
happened everything needs to be iterated
and everything that I've done and that
is out there still needs to be iterated
alright so what I'm talking about these
basic design methods I think it's also
helpful to think about how we approach
the product itself I like to break
product design down into essentially
three or four phases first off what are
all of the parts and how are they
connected let's just do an inventory of
the systems right all of the parts and
how are they connected what are the
tools what are the bits that I have to
work with here when I understand what
the
hearts are now I want to understand how
should they be connected so that people
can move through them to achieve the
things they need to do so what's the
flow through the system only when I
understand what all of the parts are how
they are connected and how people flow
through them do I start thinking about
the point of interaction
what's the interface is it a graphical
user interface or a voice user interface
or is it something in an AR VR world
where there's gestural things and haptic
feedback it doesn't matter as long as I
know the parts and how they're connected
and how people move through them the
interface actually turns out to be much
easier to design now it turns out that
the decisions that we make at the early
stages influence the decisions we make
at the subsequent stages which is kind
of why we do it in this order and we do
research the whole way along do we have
all the parts do we understand the flows
is the interface working for people and
that research always uncovers things we
didn't know or decisions that were
non-optimal and so they have this
annoying little retroactive effect where
something we learn later goes back in
time to change a decision we'd already
made but that's okay because this is
iteration and this is just how we work
so what are some methods to simplify
well I'm gonna go through just five
methods here for you first off is
subtraction this is what people start
with all the time get rid of all of the
unnecessary stuff right it's just
reduction and removal consolidation
maybe we've broken things up into too
many small components and we really
should combine a few of them where one
slightly larger thing is easier and more
meaningful so we just merge maybe we
redistribute maybe we've put things in
the wrong place or in the wrong sequence
or maybe we've combined things that
shouldn't and they need to be separated
and made distinct maybe we need to
prioritize we've treated everything
equally and so people don't know where
to look or what to do but if there's one
most common thing is it obvious what
that most
common thing to do is so how do we
prioritize in the interface and then how
do we clarify what do we need in most
cases to add to improve meaningfulness
and understandability how do we help
people make sense of what they're doing
and make predictions so here are some
examples from from Android so if you
take a look at the nav bar down here and
just as a heads up to the timer's down
here I'm totally gonna blow past that so
if you look at the nav bar down here so
you can just hold the zero for like
another eight minutes so if you look at
the nav bar down here you can see a few
years ago the icons were a little more
meaningful back home app list and then
they were geometrically simplified and
then that geometry was simplified but
they added an outer circle because now
that element had two interactions a
quick tap or a tap and hold and then in
the most recent version they've
simplified even more as they began to
introduce gestural navigation so we see
simplification over time the setup when
you get a new pixel phone the bottom
here was the sequence of steps to set up
a new device and we got clear feedback
from users too many steps took too long
I just want to turn on my phone and use
it because I'm really excited about the
new purchase so we actually went back
and did research to find out what is
absolutely necessary to set up a device
to use it as quickly as possible and
then put everything else into a deferred
setup that we will remind you about
sometime in the first seven days you own
your phone so we went from essentially
what could be as many as seventeen steps
to seven and then said tell all your
phone works have fun go use it we'll
talk to you tomorrow
or in three days or whatever it happens
to be so the simplified experience when
you set up your phone is essentially
these three things connect to a network
transfer data from an old device set up
things like your fingerprint and and
your account and then we ask you you
want to use your phone now or do you
want to finish later
most people say finish later I'm ready
to
play and then a few days later they get
a reminder that says hey you still have
a few things to do to set up your phone
and they can do it at their leisure
volume controls how many of you remember
older Android you'd be listening to
music you want to change the volume you
hit the volume button and it shows you
the ringer volume oh at least be smart
right if I'm listening to music I
probably want to change the volume of my
music but now you have to touch a little
thing that exposes more find music then
adjust the music volume so we changed it
now the little volume slider appears on
the side of the phone right where the
volume buttons are and it defaults to
the thing that is making noise at the
time you press the volume buttons
because that's probably what you wanted
to adjust right and it exposes some of
the quickest things I put it in vibrate
or put it in do not disturb or mute the
music temporarily quick settings that
little giorious wiped down from the top
that allows you to configure your phone
on the fly yeah the the options are
still the same but the original
interaction was confusing because each
one of these things had to tap zones the
icon did one thing and the label did
another and there was no visual signal
to say that was the case so in the
redesign there is just one tap zone now
they all behave the same way you just
tap and it opens up the options for you
so that was the simplification in flow
you can see this is what the old one was
to tap zones the new one single tap zone
notifications and settings people get
notifications they hate notifications
they interrupt them they get frustrated
they have no idea where to control
notifications I want to turn this off
where is it I hate that so now they're
right in the notification you got it you
swipe there's a little Settings thing
you touched that it says do you not want
to get these anymore
yes and it says great and it's done I
don't even have to go into settings
anymore I still can if I want to we
introduced digital wellbeing last year
people said I use my phone too much how
much are you using it what are you using
it on I don't know now we give them the
data and this is about clarification and
meaning right so in this particular
screens most of my time was spent
chatting with colleagues one hour and 30
minutes 193 notifications and I opened
it 73 times that day now I know I should
stop chatting with my colleagues so
there are some considerations that we
need do need to keep in mind when we are
simplifying products there are some
guardrails that help us not oversimplify
or help us identify the things we can
use those five methods on so first off
is just remember simplicity lives within
the complicated and once you find it you
can't unwind it right we just need to
find the simplicity look for it it's in
there alright so first thing complexity
moves this is watching a movie over the
past hundred years right film projector
mechanical video cassette then we had a
more digital video cassette then we had
DVD and blu-ray than we had set-top
boxes and now we've got dongles one of
the best English words ever so watching
a movie might seem easier but all we
really did was push the complexity
further down the line instead of having
to thread film off of reels and through
a projector and having a ball band a
screen now I have a television a nap and
a dongle and I need to change my inputs
and open the app and choose something
and cast it to the dongle and then hope
that the TV switches inputs and now I
can watch the movie right so it's not
necessarily less complicated it's just
complicated in a new way and place so
the more you address complication the
sneakier it becomes and the farther
ahead of you it stays so we're never
done we might have to use multiple
methods in multiple places it's good to
remember that how people perceive an
experience may actually differ from how
that experience is actually quantified
or measured sometimes things feel
simpler even if they have a few extra
steps or take a little bit of extra time
because people feel more directed they
feel more confident that they're doing
the right thing they know that they're
headed in the right direction so I think
it's simpler it might actually be more
steps and more time
airports leverage this right way finding
in airports every designer on the planet
I think fusses away finding mechanisms
but Airport wayfinding is supposed to
help you get to your baggage or or
passport control or to your connecting
flight or to the restroom or to the
restroom or to the coffee or to the
restroom and so these signs keep you
headed in the right direction and if
you've ever noticed there's a lot of
them in airports when you're standing
under one you can typically see the next
so that sense of progress keeps you
moving forward do an evaluation do a
balanced value of the of the outcome
versus the pain of the effort to achieve
it right think of it as scales am I
going to get something sufficiently
valuable to merit the pain of the effort
I put into it we can actually think of
it as a mathematical formula the
probability of interaction is a function
of the value of the outcome divided by
the work or the effort multiplied by the
confidence I have in my prediction that
what I am doing is going to get me what
I want so if the value is too low the
work is too high or I don't know what
I'm doing I'm not going to do it I'm
just gonna abandon so think about what
you're doing for these three variables
right can I provide the value can I
reduce the work can I help people feel
confident all right motivation and
tolerance we already talked about that
one right a sufficiently motivated
person will tolerate a lot of crap
in 2012 these were the sharing icons in
common use and when the companies using
them looked at their metrics they were
like who everyone's sharing our crap but
when we really really looked at the
behavior what we saw
is that there was a lot of pogo sticking
people tapping in and out I con because
no one understood what these icons meant
or what they did I mean like really
Microsoft up a gift means share right so
some cautions about quantitative data
right simple metrics rarely tell you the
whole story if you just count the number
of interactions it doesn't tell you that
someone has focused intent or purpose it
simply tells you that they're doing this
on the keyboard right are they headed
toward what they need the duration of
the interaction is not always a measure
of engagement they're not spending five
minutes or three hours on it because
they love it they're spending three
hours on it because they have no idea
what to do or how to fix the mistakes
they've made and the task completion
rate doesn't tell you that it was easy
and enjoyable it just tells you that
they finally finished it despite your
efforts so the metrics don't interpret
the subjective experience from the
qualitative or quantitative metrics so
the reminder when you get to the top of
that curve feature complete is not
experience optimized you've just checked
off the list you are at maximum
complication so when you're up here we
can do something about it right
simplification isn't easy it is possible
we do have methods we do have some core
processes we can apply and we can get to
more clarity better structure and
improved flow alright thank you and in
my eight minutes over
[Applause]
you